aucun pays gardillou
attention on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
le matin quand vous regarder dans la
glace lose it quoi en ce moment mais à
la vie est belle ah ben ouais fut bien
êtes libérés d'un poids maintenant vous
avez fait le bouquin mais dans une bien
qu'à un moment il faut savoir considérer
que chaque instant de la vie convient
été gagné par rapport à la mort vous
auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand vous
étiez petit j'avais envie d'être général
1 et puis ça m'a passé très rapidement
mais voilà mais quand j'étais petit
j'avais polytechnique vous refuser de
porter une
timide au départ janvier est générale et
j'ai jamais été générale est-ce que vous
quitteriez tout pour le grand amour bien
sûr on partirait aux philippines comme
sirven avec
mon fils et j'ai le grand amour déjà et
je veux bien quitter toulouse ne sais
pas si je pars avec ma femme quelque
part une difficulté à repartir à zéro
c'est pas un sujet quand avez vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois
j'ai pleuré pour la dernière fois quand
j'étais en prison figure
en 1996 ouais
et j'ai pleuré sur
ce que je voyais non pas sur moi et
j'ai eu beaucoup de difficulté à
entendre et à passer la nuit avec
ses cris que j'avais entendu et
effectivement j'ai perdant c'est pas
possible que ceux ci existent si mal vie
était à refaire vous changeriez quoi
je pense que je choisir un autre pays ah
ouais ouais
quel par exemple pour n'importe lequel
enfin pas celui que je vis en ce moment
mais je dis reste maintenant pour nj
reste un et je combats dans ce pays
donc vous êtes déçus de la france la
très la seule qui vous a fait le plus
mal c'est l'insulté madame joly qui me
dit vous mentez
vous flinguent vous montez montez vous
montez je vais donc vous pensez qu'elle
est instrumentalisé auquel se sert de
vous pour se faire une réputation les
deux camps se montrent alizés
puisqu'elle a eu qu'une partie du
dossier que ce avec ça qu'elle essaie de
travailler et puis elle s est une
carrière sur moi il est clair que les
stars être ah oui à l'instar maintenant
en mettant président la sncf en taule
samar bien après vous feriez quoi si
vous restez 24 heures à vivre s'il ya
des choses importantes et qui pour
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
tout cela dit c'est quand la pêche à la
crevette ou bouquet chez moi en bretagne
ou dans la région c'est à dire en
irlande et puis c'est les champignons
cèpes girolles mais également coprins
chevelus
e mail je suis intarissable sur le
champignon j'ai commencé à prendre des
champignons à 4 ans et commence à pêcher
des crevettes à 4 ans maintenant 58 ça
fait cinquante quatre angles près et
pour moi c'est le la base de la vie la
base de la vie alors le reste un
plongeur
il ya dernière personne que j'ai eu
envie de tuer alors j'ai jamais eu envie
de tuer personne jamais même eva joly
non je suis si jamais je veux quelque
chose c'est qu'elle meurt tout seul
j'ai déjà pensé au suicide ne vous êtes
chanteau là bien sûr que oui tout à fait
alors on ne peut pas vivre en prison
sans un moment pensé ce fils idéal tout
ce qui est dit sur le sujet les gens qui
la ramène en raison des nombreuses
arrivées oublier quand on est en prison
à un moment on dit mais finalement
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de vivre et
on se pose la question mais je vous dis
en ayant fait ces vies de six mois de
prison je vous dis la vie est belle donc
il faut continuer à vivre les ailiers
retourner en prison la poésie dont non
pourquoi voulez-vous sur toile on essaie
de nous faire rire trônait s'il ya
contre vous le fait de complots vous
décrire et moi j'y retrouverai puis
j'essaierai donc on se connaît on ira
voir un loïc le floch prigent qu'est ce
que la vie vous a appris
appris à la fois qu'il fallait se méfier
de tout est à la fois qu'il faut faire
confiance alors c'est très
contradictoires et je continue à
préférer faire confiance que me méfier
de tout nu alors si un petit génie là
vous proposer dès que c'est un de vos
souhaits ce serait lequel
je pense que
il faudrait que la crevette le bouquet
reviennent en bretagne il ya une
disparition de la crevette en bretagne
chez moi confié avec le jeu obligés
d'aller un peu plus loin pour la paix
chez et je sois de charme quand vous
parlez de crohn en
quatre mois et demi
en prison moi je prends ma chance
faites gaffe l'escaladé
j'en verrai
contient légal
on cherche midi éditeur